see what i'm wondering is what are some
of the other factors so it seems
proximity spatial proximity is a factor
maybe temporal in oh sorry maybe
temporal length so how long am i
spending with someone what are some of
the other factors
well you know one of the um one of the
sort of questions that i've heard asked
is
you know this could be just a
series of fantasies that happen in these
people's minds etc but you know there
are indications that for example in the
axelrod family that this creature that
uh that the wife saw independently from
the two kids in their home um left
physical tracks so for example you know
uh there were claw marks on the tree
uh when the axelrod family went out to
investigate after the second incident
with the kids
they found all these really obvious claw
marks on the tree right on the exact
tree that this the wife had seen this
creature uh uh leaning against
that's number one they also saw this
creature throwing up a lot of leaves in
the in the backyard as it was running
one of the axelrod kids got besieged by
orbs one night
in 2011 and woke up with physical marks
on his body or a lot of red
welts on his body
it looked like you know frankly it
looked like he had been beaten up um
after a night uh in which there was a
lot of this quote unquote
paranormal activity in his house and in
his bedroom but he had physical marks on
his body um and they they actually
brought him to the er just to check him
out and and make sure that he was at
home from school the following day um he
had like intense influenza-like symptoms
after that too but um you know so this
is not only a
um you know a sort of a a mind
phenomenon it does have physical effects
on the environment
so you know it could be both
but um you know i wanted to emphasize
that there are physical effects um in
the environment as well
and just to add to just a reminder the
health consequences for people who come
into contact with these phenomena not
just at the ranch i mean you can look at
the highly publicized cases uh where
navy pilots have encountered ufos
without being too specific or giving
away personal information you can bet
that there's a chance that some of those
have had these experiences as well when
they go home
it's not just poltergeist type activity
there are severe health consequences
there are diseases perhaps the your
audience kurt will remember recent
comments by dr gary nolan where he
admits he's was contacted by cia to look
into some of these long-term health
consequences for people who encounter
ufos nothing to do with skinwalker ranch
but people who get too close for too
long to ufos have severe medical and
health consequences that last for a long
time we need to understand that you know
we need to understand how that works uh
it's not just a weird stuff that they
see in their rooms at night it's
diseases and health consequences to put
their lives in danger kit green wrote a
paper about it
before
asap for bass it's one of the 38 durds
the reports that were
funded by bass to establish a sort of a
baseline for different aspects of what
ossap was going to study
they contacted these different
professionals professors phds to look
into specific topics
that was
related to their own level of expertise
hypersonics for example uh most of the
people who wrote those papers didn't
know they're writing it as part of a ufo
study funded by dia
but they wrote it anyway projecting
what our state of the art knowledge of
in a particular specialty is
projecting it out over uh 40 or 50 years
one of those papers one of those 38
dirds written by dr kick green
neuroscientist
was looking at the medical effects
that work
has inspired dr gary nolan and others to
take it a little bit further and look at
what are the health consequences of
coming into proximity contact with the
ufo